[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Today,
we're moving on,
and we're moving
into what's really
happening with those electrons.
And I framed this on Monday by
telling you that the Rutherford
atom wasn't going to
make it more than 10
to the minus 11 seconds-ish
because classical E&M would
tell you that the electron, if
it's going around like this,
is radiating energy,
and so it spirals down
into that positively
charged nucleus.
So Rutherford got it
right in the sense
that you got all this positive
charge concentrated in this one
tiny little volume
in the middle,
and the electrons
are way out there.
That's the planetary model.
But we needed some new
theory to understand
why the whole thing
was stable, and that's
where Bohr comes along,
and that's what we're
going to talk about today.
Now, we need to feel
our oneness with waves.
Now, I think probably most of
about waves, but since we're
going to be talking about
them a whole lot today
and as we go forward, I
want to make sure we're all
on the same page.
So here's a wave.
Well, we know about water waves.
They move a meter a second.
Sound waves a little
faster, right?
And you've got these
characteristics of a wave--
the frequency of the
wave, the wavelength.
And so I just want to make
sure that we're all together
on this because we're
going to be talking
about these variables a lot.
So if you have a wavelength,
that might be in meters.
How many meters do
you have per wave?
We're getting somewhere here.
If you have the frequency-- and
I'll use this notation here.
You can use f.
You might see f sometimes.
I like using nu.
And if you have the
frequency, well, that's
going to be the number of
waves per second, for example.
And so the speed is going to
be the two of them multiplied
together.
And I know a lot of
you have seen this,
but again, I want
to get it up here.
So it's going to be
meters per second
if these are the units that
I'm using, seconds and meters.
Now, if you're light--
light as in light--
then you have a speed that
is a constant in vacuum,
and we know that.
So the speed of light--
so for light, let's put
that right underneath.
For light, the speed is
c, which equals 3 times 10
to the eighth meters per second.
OK, just getting
to some good stuff.
So if I wanted to
know, for example, how
to go back and forth
between frequency
and wavelength
for light, well, I
can just use this relationship.
So let's put an
example up there.
So for example, if you're red
light, so if you're red light,
then you might have a frequency
of around, let's say, 450.
There's a range, but 450
terahertz would be a frequency.
And so now I can
get the wavelength
because I have
that relationship.
So the wavelength
for red light is
c over nu, which is going
to be equal to 3 times 10
to the eighth meters per
second divided by 450 times 10
to the 12th per second, right?
That's the measurement of
hertz is 1 over seconds, right?
That's frequency,
1 over seconds.
That gives me a number that
seems like it's pretty small,
0.000000667 meters.
And so we could use
a different unit
like nanometers, which is
just 10 to the minus ninth.
So we could call that the
wavelength of red light, 667
nanometers.
Now, I'm doing this all slowly
and carefully because we're
going to be doing
this a lot, and so I
want to make sure that
you're comfortable with this.
And we're going to add something
to this in just a minute.
If I was blue light--
where's blue light?
Let's put blue light--
I'm going to leave
red light here.
And we'll put blue
light right above it
so that you can
see them together.
So blue might be
something like, oh,
a frequency of 650 terahertz,
so higher frequency.
And that would give you
a wavelength of something
like 460 nanometers.
I'm putting these
both here because I'll
be comparing other aspects
of these colors later.
Now comes back-- no.
That's our oneness moment
with waves and light,
and now we come
back to our story,
our detective story of what's
happening inside of atoms,
and it really requires
us to go back.
I said Bohr had some
postulates about quantization.
There was work going on at
the time already related
to quantization.
So I want to share
with you that work
because it's what inspired
Bohr, and then we'll
do the Bohr model.
But also just I want to get
you thinking about what this
all means.
So if you think about
music, you can think
about these two instruments.
This might feel like--
the violin might feel like
something where you can
just play continuous notes,
whereas here you can't.
It's discrete.
I can't play any
notes in between.
Something is discrete.
It's quantized.
Well, that's pretty obvious.
You look at those.
You're like, OK,
that makes sense.
There's some things that
aren't as obvious, like here.
Oh, notice what's
in the calendar.
That's a screen.
Now a screen from far enough
away might not look quantized,
but then when you look
at it closely, it is.
It's pixels.
There's nothing in between.
The thing is that at the time,
people thought about the world
in a certain way.
There's some things where
it's just obvious they're
violins like light.
And then they're
like, wait a second.
These things are
acting like xylophones.
What's going on?
So Planck's contribution
was really--
he was one of the first
kind of deep thinkers
to talk about quantization, and
it was quantization of light.
It was quantization of light.
And so what he said-- and this
is together with Einstein,
and I'll show you what
Einstein did in a minute.
So it's called the
Planck-Einstein relation.
And what he said is that
the energy of a photon--
so Planck-- why did
I just go all caps?
I don't know.
There's a reason,
Planck-Einstein.
They said that the energy
for light-- the energy
is related to the frequency
through a constant.
And so in particular, E
equals h times the frequency.
Now, this was revolutionary.
It might just look like
a simple relationship.
Oh, and by the way,
this is a constant
named Planck's constant.
I'm going lowercase--
Planck's constant.
And, like other
constants, it has
a value that doesn't change.
So that value for
Planck's constant is in--
I'll give it to you
in two different units
so we have it up here, 6.26--
no-- 6.62-- sorry--
6.626 times 10 to the
minus 34 joules-second.
Or it's also equal
to 4.136 times 10
to the minus 15th
electronvolt-seconds.
Notice the units are in energy
times time, Planck's constant.
And you can see that it must
be because this is energy
and this is 1 over
time, the frequency.
So it's got to have those
units for that to work.
But this-- did I make a mistake?
I'm worried.
The dates are still
hitting me hard.
I'm still thinking about
that, having nightmares.
100 years off, 90 years off.
I'm good.
So what they saw is that
light had a frequency,
but it also had somehow
this unit of energy,
a unit, a discrete
unit of energy
that you can now calculate
using Planck's constant.
And that was revolutionary.
That was not what
people thought.
And it really all came
home in what Einstein did,
which was the
experiments that he
won the Nobel Prize
for-- his deeper thinking
was in relativity, but he
won the Nobel Prize for this
because it was absolutely
essential to further
this idea of quantization and
show it with an experiment.
And because it was
so important, I
want to share that experiment
because when Einstein did
was really quite amazing.
He shined light on a
metal, and what he saw--
so this is called the
photoelectric effect--
photoelectric effect.
And this is where you
take a piece of metal-
and they knew there were
electrons in there, right?
That discovery had happened.
So they knew there
were electrons in--
and they also knew if you
hit this metal with energy,
the electrons could come off.
I mean, after all, that's
what the cathode ray tube was.
It was electrons coming
off of a piece of metal.
And in that experiment,
you hook up a voltage,
but here he shined light.
And so if you take, for example,
different frequencies of light
and you shine them on this
same piece of metal-- so let's
go red and then let's go
green and then let's go blue.
Now, if you shine red light on
the metal, nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
But OK, we know if
you just crank up
the intensity of the light,
something's got to come off.
You're putting all this energy--
no.
Why?
Because the particles, the
packets, the quantized amounts
of energy that that
kind of light can have
is determined here.
So what Einstein says
is, well, OK, then these
must be particles.
They must have some
energy associated
with a particle that follows
this relationship equals h nu.
And notice that doesn't
depend on intensity.
It just depends on frequency.
So I might be hitting this metal
with more and more of them,
but each one only has
the same amount of energy
limited by that relationship.
So if I want to hit those
electrons with more energy,
I've got to change
the frequency.
And so what was found
in this experiment
is that, well, maybe
here you get nothing.
So here you get nothing.
How am I going to write that?
OK, nothing.
I just won't write it.
Here, maybe you get electrons.
And here, maybe you
get faster electrons
because these fundamental
particles of energy of light
have different energies, right?
So now we can calculate it.
We can calculate the
energy of that red light,
and we calculate the
energy of the blue light
because I have
now E equals h nu.
And if I plug it in,
which I won't do,
you get something like
1.8 electronvolts.
And if you do the
same thing for blue,
from the
Planck-Einstein relation
you get the energy
is 2.7 electronvolts.
So what Einstein did in this
experiment which was so crucial
is he measured.
He changed the
frequency of light
that you shine on
this metal, and what
he saw is that there was
nothing, nothing, nothing,
nothing.
And then all of a sudden
you literally had,
if you plot the
kinetic energy of the--
I'll write it out here--
ejected electron-- so that's
what's being plotted there.
You plot that versus the--
I said it wasn't
going to use f--
versus the frequency of the
light, nothing, nothing,
nothing.
And then all of a sudden
there's a linear relationship
between them.
That explains it
because these things
were made of these particles
that were called photons.
So photons.
Now, while this was
blowing their minds
and winning prizes and
all that, Bohr came along.
Now remember, this is
what I mean by dates.
Apart from the
dates, we know now
there was a lot of time between
those experiments, especially
Dalton and Thompson.
And that's where
we were on Monday.
So Bohr was looking at all this.
Remember, he wrote
the paper where
he said it is with great
interest the Rutherford atom,
meaning it's wrong.
It needs fixing.
Meanwhile, Bohr's looking
over at Einstein and Planck
and he's like, wait a second.
Let me get some of
that quantization stuff
because if it works for
light, what if it also
works for electrons?
What if it also
And so he's looking
at this stuff going on
with Planck and Einstein, and
he applied it to the electron
in Rutherford's atom.
That's what he did.
That's what Bohr did.
He said, you guys
got your light thing.
I'm going after the atom.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make just actually
a fairly simple postulate.
Why is that up there?
Let's go.
I'm going to say that for
me, the quantization is
going to happen with
the angular momentum.
So Bohr came along, and
he said that the angular
momentum of the electron--
so L equals mvr, right?
Remember, we listed the Bohr
postulates, and one of them
was that Newtonian
mechanics would hold.
Angular momentum, mvr.
But there's something
added to it.
He said that that angular
momentum could only have
discrete values, quantization.
So he said that this is
quantized, and he was specific.
He said it could only be
some number, some integer
times Planck's constant
divided by 2 pi.
Why not?
When in doubt, divide by 2 pi.
As you all know, that has to do
with just making math easier.
Now, that's the
angular momentum,
and he said it's quantization.
And n-- n is the key here
because n is this thing that
says that it must be some unit.
This is like the unit.
It's like that photon energy.
It comes in units, but it
comes in units of integers.
So you could have 1 or you
could have 2 or 3 but not 1.5.
That's quantization.
So n had to be 1, 2, 3.
It had to be some integer.
And oh, here we go.
Watch this.
We're going to call
it a quantum number.
I should have written
that in all caps.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you for that.
It's our first quantum
number, and we've only
known each other for a week--
a week.
Here we are.
We're quantization things.
Quantum number because it's a
number that counts quantumness,
quantization.
This is how you get the
quantization from this.
So it's a quantum number.
Now here's the thing.
I will not derive
Bohr's model for you.
I will tell you what it is.
And if you want, you can
look up the derivation.
It's actually really
fairly straightforward.
It basically has to do
with this one assumption,
quantization of the
angular momentum
of that electron,
combined with F equals ma
and the electron is stable.
It's not accelerating in.
And when you do
that, what you get--
let's put this-- no.
Let's put that back up.
So what you get with Bohr's
model is the following.
You get three extremely
important outcomes.
First, you get that the radius
of that electron is quantized.
Then you get that it's energy.
The energy that it's allowed
to have is also quantized.
And finally, you get that
its transitions are--
you got it.
Thank you-- quantized.
So if you plug stuff in and
you do the Bohr derivation
for the hydrogen
atom, what you get
is that the radius
of that electron
is equal to n squared
times a constant divided
by the atomic number.
And this constant is
called the Bohr radius.
It's got a value of
0.0529 nanometers,
and it's also called the
Bohr radius if you want.
But that's its value.
And then if do the same--
now if you look at energy--
so energy, the equation for
that comes out to be minus 13.6
times the atomic
number squared divided
by n squared in units of eV.
Those are the two
key results that
come from Bohr's postulates
and from Bohr doing this--
doing that.
And we're going to talk
about each one of these.
All right, so if I--
OK.
So let's go one at a time.
No.
So let's talk about the
radius for a minute.
Let's talk about the radius.
So if I look at the radius
and I'm a nucleus here--
so I've got like
some positive charge
in the middle and some nucleons
and stuff, what I'm saying--
I'm sorry, some
nuclei neutrons--
is that the electron can
only be at certain values.
This distance r can
only be at these values,
and that's dictated
by the quantization
number, the quantum number.
n equals 1 would be the closest.
You can see that
from the formula.
And n equals 2, and so on.
And this is not
necessarily drawn to scale.
You can see that for n
equals 1 and z equals 1,
the electron is simply at
the distance of the constant,
0.5-ish angstroms,
0.05 nanometers, right?
At n equals 2,
it's 4 times that.
Oh, yeah?
STUDENT: What's the z?
PROFESSOR: The z is
the atomic number.
And that comes in--
let's put that here.
And that comes in
because it tells us
how many positive
charges there are,
how many protons there
are in the nucleus.
And that comes in when
you do F equals ma.
That's how it comes
into the Bohr equations.
And r is a distance, and
n is the quantum number,
and a0 is a constant.
z is the atomic
number in both cases.
This is mind-blowing
because it tells you
that that's where the electrons
are in the atom orbit,
in the atom, but they're
only those distances.
Remember, quantization
means nothing else.
Think about that.
I'm saying that that electron
can't be anywhere else.
It must be this distance,
or it must be this distance.
So this was a big deal.
People were like, what?
It didn't compute.
It didn't make sense.
But this is what
they were starting
to see, that this was the only
way to explain what they saw,
which we'll come to when
we talk about transitions.
So this would be the radius.
And when you look at the
energy, it's just as--
I'm going to use--
yeah, I'll put it here.
So you take that
equation for the energy
of an electron in an atom,
and you take z equals 1.
If z equals 1, then the
energy is quantized,
and it's minus 13.6 divided
by n squared electronvolts.
And if I just draw this
as energy going up--
so if I just draw
this, then what
that means is that I've got
one line down here showing
kind of the energy level.
So this would be minus 13.6 eV.
And then I've got
another line here,
and this would be minus 3.4 eV.
And then I've got
another one here, minus--
let's see-- 1.5-ish eV.
And I'm going to
start to get crowded.
As you can see, they're going to
get closer and closer until you
get to some level
here, which would
be like n equals infinity.
And then above that, zero.
Above that is free.
The electron is free.
When its n is
infinity, when it's
gone through all the quantum
numbers up to infinity,
it's free.
And that is called ionization,
taking it out of the atom
and making it not part of
an atom anymore but just out
there free able to
do what it wants.
You've ionized it.
You've taken it out.
We'll come back to this
concept multiple times.
These are the energy
levels for an electron,
and they are also quantized.
They could only be
this value or only
that value or only that value.
They cannot be anything
else in between.
That was revolutionary
at the time.
So this would be
like n equals 1.
Sorry.
That's not E. That's eV.
n equals 1, n
equals 2, and so on.
Now the third point that
I made is that it also
tells us about transitions.
This was also
absolutely essential,
and this was the key piece to
understanding what they saw.
And so we'll get to
that in a few minutes.
What do I mean by a transition?
I mean that an electron is
in an atom at some level,
and it moves to another level.
But now the point is
that if it can only
be in these discrete
quantized levels,
then when it moves
from one to another,
those changes in energy
are also discrete values.
There are only certain
changes in energy
that that electron
can experience.
And there's even
more which is that
what can cause those
changes or what
happens as a result
of those changes
is the interaction with light.
And we're all the way
back to here, photons.
Think about it this way.
If I take a ball and
I have it up here,
it's got some mgh in it, right?
And I drop it, and
now it's got some KE.
More energy was in
gravitation, was
stored in mgh, gravitational
potential energy,
and then I let it go.
Well, for an electron,
this is its ground state.
This is the kind of happy place.
So this would be
like a ground state,
and these would be
all excited states.
It would be like excited states.
So that would be like lifting
the electron up and letting go.
But when you let it go,
it's not kinetic energy
that that transfers into.
It's photon energy.
Photon energy gets emitted from
electrons changing their levels
in an atom.
Light is an absolutely
intricate part of this system.
And not only that, but
everything is quantized.
I almost need a
moment, but I'm OK.
I'm going to keep going.
This was our big deal,
a really big deal
because now I can tell you--
OK, there we go--
because now I could tell you,
for example, that if that's
the second orbit in hydrogen
and that's the first orbit,
I can tell you what
frequency light
is emitted if you go
from n equals 2 to n
equals 1 because the change
in energy from n equals 2 to n
equals 1 is nothing more
than minus 13.6 eV times--
well, it's the final state
minus the initial state, right?
The final state is
1 over 1 squared,
and the initial state
is 1 over 2 squared.
All I've done is pull out the
13.6, but these are just--
these are just the
Bohr-model energies,
and I'm just taking
the difference.
This is equal to Ef minus Ei.
It's the change in energy.
So in this case, it's
minus 10.2 electronvolts
and going from the second
orbit, quantized orbit,
down to the first.
And I can now tell you because
of what we did in the beginning
that that would emit a photon
of frequency 2.5 times 10
to the 15th hertz.
That's the energy
difference, and that energy
goes into producing a photon--
goes into producing a
photon, and we can tell you
exactly what that frequency is.
So these are the
kinds of transitions
that the Bohr model
explains, and it
explains energy changing
from electron transitions
to photons.
So what are the
implications of this?
Oh, there's the question
that I just answered.
If this is hydrogen, z equals 1.
The implications of
this are groundbreaking,
and it explained
what people were
seeing because you
could be talking
about angstroms already.
Angstrom looked up, and he's
like, well, you guys think
it's a rainbow, but
I'm not seeing that.
I'm seeing discrete
lines all over the place.
And that's what he saw
when he looked at the sun.
Don't look at the sun.
It's not a good idea,
but Angstrom did.
And now he said, well, but
there are all these lines,
and the wavelengths
that he tabulated
happened to come on
this sort of thousands
of angstrom kind of scale.
And so he liked that,
and chemists love it,
and that's why the angstrom
is named what it is,
10 to the minus 10th meters.
Chemists love it because
a bond is a few angstroms.
Spectroscopists like nanometers.
They're like,
thousands are too big.
We don't like thousands.
We want to work with hundreds.
So spectroscopists
use nanometers.
Other people, chemists,
whose angstroms.
I say can't we all
just really get along?
And it's fine.
Don't make spectroscopists
angry, really.
I did it once.
Now on Friday, you
are going to get
the most accurate
spectroscope that
has been made by humans
in your goodie bag,
and you'll be able
to look at the fact
that the world is
not continuous.
These frequencies, wavelengths
that are coming out
are not continuous.
If you take a tube of H2 gas and
you apply an enormous voltage
to it, you will excite
electrons in the H2 molecules.
As they go back down,
they will emit photons,
and what will you see?
Only certain values.
Well, this is what
people were doing.
They were looking out into the
universe-- which, by the way,
is 75% hydrogen. And
they're like, really?
The hydrogen economy.
[LAUGHTER]
We-- we-- they were looking
now and seeing discrete lines
all over the place.
How to explain it?
The Bohr model is
what explained it.
You will be able to see these
discrete lines yourselves
with the goodie bag on Friday.
But if you do this, this is what
you might see from hydrogen.
And there were a
lot of people trying
to understand this at the
time, Balmer and Rydberg.
And I'm not going to go
through-- they came up
with sort of partial formula.
They were empirically based.
But Bohr-- it was
only the Bohr model
that could explain it all.
It was only the Bohr model.
And the reason is that all the
transitions were out there,
and you need the complete
picture of these changes
in energy between these levels.
You need to know about
that to understand
all those transitions.
And at the time, it
was a real thing.
If you were like, I want
to get something named
after myself in
science, you'd be like
let me go and find a new set
of transitions, which are just
basically lines, right?
It's that you're not seeing
a continuous spectrum
in some part of space.
You're instead seeing
discrete lines.
And look at this, right?
So like Lyman--
you could go down
to n equals 1 like we did there,
2 to 1, so from here to here.
But you could also
go from 3 down to 1.
You could also go from
4, and that's a series.
Then you could also transition
not from to 1 but to 2 or to 3,
and each one of
those is a series.
And then I think finally
they're like, OK, no more names.
After Pfund, we're
done with naming.
But all those series
are still there.
Those are the
allowed transitions.
So you can also imagine
that it's not just emission.
So we've been talking
about emission.
You get these lines when an
electron goes down in energy.
Remember, like the
ball, the mgh goes down.
It gives off photons in
these quantized energies,
but it can be the opposite.
You could shine light.
So I could get a continuous
spectrum here and shine it
on an atom, and that atom
absorbs light literally
by exciting electrons.
An electron is in some state,
maybe the ground state,
and some energy comes along
that exactly takes it up
to one of these states.
But it can't sort of
take you up there.
It's got to take you there--
quantization.
That's why you see
these lines here.
These are the places where
that atom can absorb a photon
because it exactly
corresponds to a transition
from one discrete
level to another.
So it works both ways,
absorbing photon energy,
promoting electrons up.
And when we do X-rays, we
just ionize everything.
But right now, we're
staying within the potential
of the atom.
So we're staying
within these levels,
absorbing or emitting energy.
So I could answer
questions like this.
If you look at a
question like this--
I forget.
I think this might be from
a couple of years ago quiz,
so you might get something
like this tomorrow.
No, you won't.
I just looked at a
few faces, and no
because we're talking
about it today.
So you wouldn't get it
tomorrow because, remember,
you only get quizzed on things
that we did ending on Monday.
It wouldn't be fair otherwise.
But next week, OK.
What's the lowest-energy
photon shown?
Which one is it?
These are photons now.
We think of these as photons.
Red.
High wavelength, lower energy.
OK, good.
That was over here.
Now what about what
transition give us
the line at 639 nanometers?
Hello, [? Humana. ?]
639 nanometers.
So I want to know what
electron transition did that.
Well, to solve that problem--
to solve that problem, I
need to do some erasing.
Maybe I'll just draw
it in here because what
you have is minus
13.6 eV times--
I'm assuming z equals 1 because
did I say it was hydrogen?
I did, hydrogen. z equals 1.
So z goes away, 1 squared.
So minus 13.6 eV times 1 over
the final state squared minus 1
over the initial quantum state
squared quantum number squared.
So that's going to equal
639 nanometers, which we now
know we can convert, thanks
to Planck and Einstein,
into an energy.
We now know that,
a photon energy.
It's that photon, that unit,
that discrete unit that
does it, and this is
1.94 eV because it
comes from 639 nanometers.
Back and forth, back and forth.
We've got to get into that
mode and into that mood.
Back and forth, energy,
frequency, wavelength.
And so I won't do the
math here, but the answer
comes into something
like it's the 4 to 3.
4 to 3 is the transition
that gives you that.
We're not going to go--
some day.
We're not going to
go kind of all--
this is a fairly
simple one to see.
We're not going to go like n
equals 528 to n equals 7,000,
but some simple kind
of back and forth.
Just get into that mode of
looking at these transitions
as changes in energy,
which means the emission
or absorption of a photon.
That's what I want you
to get out of this.
And you can go further than
that and answer questions
like power questions.
So here's a question.
If your favorite radio
station broadcasts
at a frequency of 107.9--
I'm not saying that's mine,
but you got to groove out--
and a power output
of 50 kilowatts,
how many photons are emitted
by the transmitter each second?
I just want to give you this
as another example of thinking
about this.
Light, energy-- light to
energy, photons, particles.
And here, you can get that by
simply knowing what power is.
And if you know what power
is, it's watts per second.
Sorry, watts is
joules per second.
And so the energy here is h nu.
And I won't go
through all the math,
but I'll leave the answer here.
You get 7.12 times 10 to the
minus 26 joules per photon.
Now, how did I get that?
I got that because I
know the frequency.
Why am I using joules?
Remember, I put them both
up there-- joules, eV.
Ah, because I know my power,
which is 50 kilowatts, which
is 50,000 joules per second.
And so I've got
joules in the power.
I just decided to
stick with joules.
Joules, eV, joules,
eV, back and forth.
They're just units.
If you're not familiar with
changing back and forth,
you should do a little practice.
And this gives you
something like 7 times 10
to the 29th photons per second.
So you can think about power,
photons, light, energy.
If I shine that many--
if I shine that many
on Einstein's medal,
will the electrons come off?
That seems like a lot.
We don't know because we need
to know how much energy it takes
to liberate the
electron, and then
that ties into the frequency.
Radio waves are
much lower energy,
much, much lower energy.
Now, this gets me
to why this matters,
and that's how I want
to end today's lecture
in the last five minutes because
we talked about emission,
electrons transitioning
from their discrete orbitals
as a way of emitting
or absorbing.
And so you if you
have different atoms,
there's hydrogen. These
are the absorption lines--
absorption lines.
Carbon has absorption lines.
Oxygen, nitrogen,
sulfur, so lots of things
have absorption lines.
Why does this matter?
Well, of course, because
of the refrigerator.
I love this plot.
This is a plot of
the refrigerator.
This is the size
of the refrigerator
as a function of year.
The date only goes to 2002,
but it's roughly stable now.
Does anybody know
what's limiting
the size of the refrigerator?
It was going up and up and up
a lot, and then it stopped.
Does anybody know
what limits that?
STUDENT: The average
height [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: It's the
width of the doorway.
It's the width of the doorway.
That's why we don't-- that's
why people get a second
refrigerator.
And there's energy use.
Energy Star program, big deal.
Big deal.
But I'm talking
about refrigerators
for a different reason.
I'm talking about refrigerators
because until the 1980s,
the way we did cooling
was with a chemical called
chlorofluorocarbon.
This is a chemistry
class, and we're
going to be talking about--
when we talk about
why this matters,
we connect to the chemistry.
Well, the chemistry
there was critical.
There was a molecule there
called chlorofluorocarbon
or CFC.
And the thing
about that molecule
is that its absorption,
the chlorofluorocarbon--
so let's write it
down here, CCl3F.
There's a gas phase, so we
put the little lower script g.
That molecule has
its own absorption.
It has its own absorption,
and it has its own reaction,
and so do other things.
But it has a really
important reaction
because when it
absorbs UV rays, then
it doesn't just like then
like electrons get pumped up.
No, the whole thing reacts.
And so this thing degrades
into CCl2F plus chlorine gas,
and that's once it's up maybe
in the atmosphere, which
it was getting released
all the time because
of the refrigerators.
And the thing is that the
chlorine gas would then
react with ozone, and this
would go to ClO plus O2,
and here's the problem.
I mean, we're
already at a problem,
but now it's a big
problem because--
you can already tell.
But I've got ClO, and
that's really reactive.
So what happens is
ClO, which was a gas--
I'm just being careful
here with my subjects--
would react with atomic
oxygen to give you
O2 and the chlorine atom back.
And here's the thing.
Now I've got my
chlorine atom again.
These are very reactive
atoms in the atmosphere.
They love ozone.
And so this cycle
for one CFC molecule
would happen 100,000
times, roughly,
before that chlorine
kind of goes
away and does something else--
100,000 ozone molecules per CFC.
Why does that matter?
Well, it matters because--
I love this plot.
This is the energy of light
from the sun hitting our planet.
So this is the energy that
you get, and look at this.
This is the sun at the
top of the atmosphere.
Here it is on Earth, the red.
Look at these things here.
If you could only
see in this spectrum,
the world would be dark because
there's no light on the planet.
Why?
Because it's all absorbed in
the upper atmosphere by water.
Absorption-- it's the
same principle, Bohr.
Bohr's idea of electrons
getting promoted
when they absorb
light is happening,
and it's protecting us because
right here, see, that's the UV.
Low wavelength, high energy.
UV, O3.
Look at that.
Look at what it's taking out.
That little sliver of
yellow is critical.
And ozone was doing the
job, and it still is.
But if we tear all that
ozone out with these CFCs,
we have a crisis.
And that led to what is one of
the greatest policy decisions
which was made in 1987-- it's
called the Montreal Protocol--
to essentially globally
ban-- the US led this.
This is a great example of
how policy is so critical.
The US led this
effort to ban CFCs,
and we're almost back
to normal ozone levels,
and we avoid this.
And by the way, if
this had happened,
the prediction at the time
was roughly 280 million
additional cases of skin
cancer over this generation.
This is a very big
deal, and it all
comes back to
absorption of electrons
by atoms and molecules.
See you guys on Friday.